yeah I think this this was most complete
that I've I've played I feel good about
the timing you're a lot of lot of balls
throw it on time and obviously that the
line played fantastic you know I think
we've had Tom just told me seven sacks
in the last six games it was pretty
remarkable as Aaron Rodgers after the
best game of his career
it still feels weird to say it but it
was perfect passer rating five touchdown
passes a touchdown on the ground and the
Packers rolled over the Raiders it's
Sunday statement time our draft that we
do every Monday during the season I've
got the trivia question determine who
gets the first pick I think I know who
the first pick is going to be here's the
question Lamar Jackson has now surpassed
500 yards rushing in two straight
seasons only one other quarterback in
NFL history has 500 or more rushing
yards in each of his first two seasons
who is that quarterback oh man I'm gonna
go with Randall Cunningham camp it's the
second straight day the Cam Newton's
been the answer to the trivia question I
look for very different reasons but
honor Cam Newton okay it's hot I mean
these these are these are not easy yes
no they're doesn't win especially you
talking about history right right now
he's a Bobby Douglas I don't know I was
thinking I know I went down Steve Young
I was thinking of all a bunch of
different people all right so okay I'm
gonna take especially because last week
after seeing what he did on Monday night
against the Detroit Lions yeah flexing
on what he did against the Cowboys and
it all started in the loss to the Eagles
that's when Aaron Rodgers began to play
at an MVP level and even though the
stats drive that consideration I think
it means more than the stats it's what
are you doing to help your team win and
he's the guy at the center of that
universe and he's the guy who is making
that team go and he's the guy who is
holding that team together through some
sluggish offensive performances and he
didn't get passive aggressive and he
made sure on Monday night when guys were
dropping passes not to to have a
and you know a nasty reaction and yell
at guys he's being very patient with
this team he knows that these are young
guys who are trying to grow and develop
and it paid off yesterday everybody
stepped up everybody got it done and
Aaron Rodgers career game in year 1112
as a starter and it was an amazing thing
to say it was I mean yeah he'd
epitomizes what we talked about with MVP
I mean this is an offense that I don't
think anybody don't look at and go wow
there's great talent everywhere what
they do have is a good system and
they're running the ball and they have
some creative play-action design and
then because of Rodgers talent himself
that allows the rest of the guys around
him to look better than they are
especially at the receiving position and
of course you know the other thing too
you just got to remember is you know
Matt Lafleur and company can design
play-action passes that maybe they never
even dreamt up before because they've
just go well I mean we got this guy any
any place on the field as a capability
for us to draw one up and that adds to
the offense as well so I'm with you
there and I'm going I'm staying in the
in the NFC North I mean I'm her cousins
I am I mean the cousins and the Vikings
in general but and and I you know of
course I want to add cousins in there
because a lot of people have been on him
about it no things like that he was
phenomenal and it's three weeks in a row
but I think the bigger picture too is
just the Minnesota Vikings in general to
what you've said really you know all
last week these are these are usually
the games they would lose we've come off
some impressive wins and everything's
looking good and then we go on the road
didn't lay an egg in Detroit or
something like that we have we've seen
that a lot I feel like over the last few
years for the Minnesota Vikings so for
them to answer the bell one more time
and then not answer it through their
defense because their defense was not
special yesterday I mean Detroit was
moving the ball Stafford was throwing
laser beams all over the field but Kirk
Cousins continued to answer and Mike
Zimmer didn't allow the Vikings to crawl
into a shell and when they got the lead
and go oh let's just run the ball and
well my defense will help us get out I
think he realized what the game was and
they needed to stay aggressive on the
offensive side of the ball and cousins
capital
that play-action pass on second and six
with the game still very much in the
balance 35 Lions get the ball back you
know I've seen this movie many times
before and seeing Kirk Cousins on the
sidelines as the Lions were driving down
to score the touchdown that would make
it 35 30 kind of pacing knowing I got to
keep myself in this zone and I feel like
Chris week-to-week he's trying to keep
himself in this zone where he's upset
right and it's gonna be harder to do the
better he plays because he's gonna get
more and more praise and he's got to
remember how it felt hearing guys like
me say basically the Vikings have to
figure out how to escape this contract
that's how bad Kirk Cousins is and after
20 games as the starting quarterback now
look I'm not a big fan of guys getting
indignant when we happen to point out
that they're not earning their money
because he wasn't but I think he's
trying to stay in that sweet spot that
he's found that very narrow lane where
he's upset and he's angry every week and
he's playing better and better because
of it and maybe some some of the members
of the coaching staff are kind of
prodding him a little bit to get him to
that point where he's in that right that
debt he said I play better when I'm
ticked off maybe the coaches like how to
keep you alive dad that's what he's
found again he found another like this
is it that's what he did he's not doing
doesn't wobble away from that debt that
groove that he's found you're trying to
take that zone and extend it all the way
through the end of the season yeah so
good choice by you two NFC North
quarterbacks take over how abouts an AFC
South quarterback in Jacoby perset okay
we think about it we are less than two
months removed from the stunning news
that Andrew Luck was retiring and it was
very easy at that point to write off the
Colts like what are they gonna be what
are they gonna do they've got your Cobra
set and they're happy with Jacoby recep
ADIZ not Andrew Luck well yesterday
Jacobi % had a great great game against
a great opponent and any of these times
even though the two quarterbacks are
never on the field at the same time
you've got to Shawn Watson vs. Jacobi
percent one week after we saw Ajanta
shawn watson versus patrick mahomes
right this is an opportunity for perset
to prove that he belongs in that
conversation of the best quarterbacks in
the NFL and he delivered it's amazing to
think about where the Colts are right
now yeah and look
your luck couldn't come back this year
if he wanted to because he'd have to
pass through waivers and someone grabbed
him but I think right now the Colts are
fine they don't yes I mean we are
learning this is another great year of
we're learning that it's more than just
about the quarterback in football except
when it's Aaron Rodgers well I mean you
know it's it's not they've helped the
quarterback out too - even as great as
he is he needed help I mean and then
they've done that you know with at least
a system and a run game and play-action
passes like we talked about but yes
Jacoby purse it's been phenomenal he was
phenomenal yesterday and and I think you
know the game is not managed for him I
mean they just go out and play and he
throws the ball all over the field and
it's deep shots and deep crosses and
everything like that and you know he's
very good in the pocket he can he
battles back from adversity you know had
the sack fumble early on in the game
where you know he comes back from that
you know this touchdown pass here yeah
this is a phenomenal catch but just like
Tony Dungy said last night - it's a
phenomenal throw - because you got to be
safe in that situation you don't want to
put that ball you know in a place where
it can be intercepted that ball either
gets caught by your guy or it goes off
of his hands out of bounds and and that
that was that was great - but let me
just say Kobe percent yeah the Colts
have got to prove to me that they can
win the games are supposed to win
they're the flipside of the Vikings
right they stumbled against the Chargers
in hindsight how the heck do you lose to
the chart yeah they lost at home to the
Raiders and that shouldn't have happened
you're right they need to win the games
they're supposed to win and they've got
some games coming up that are gonna fall
in that category
Denver coming to town next week that's a
game you got to win right at the
Steelers that's the game you gotta win
the Dolphins I mean if they don't go
three-and-oh these next three games yeah
that that's the concern that they can
rise up when it's a great opponent but
then they slink when it's a battle yeah
no they've definitely seemed to have
that a little bit to a degree even you
know even that Falcons game was in the
ballot balance for a while - you might
have said that maybe I wasn't list I
didn't you weren't good but either way
alright that's enough of your pick and
the cult's my next statements gonna go
to the guy two guys from last night who
I wanted more from Zeek Elliott and
DeMarcus Lawrence yeah they made a
Sunday statement you know this is these
are two guys that are the highest-paid
of their position or close to the
highest-paid at their position in all of
football Zee Kelly it is DeMarcus
Lawrence is right
up there with the coil Max and the Aaron
Donald's of the world and they had not
performed to the level that they should
or what they're being paid for for what
jerry jones expects out of them as far
as performance on the field and last
night they let you know they were out
there early on zeke elliot ran with you
no anger
it was explosiveness from the second he
took off down hill got the ball I mean
hey that one that first run that got
them down to the one-yard line when he
ran over Malcolm Jenkins I went oh that
looks like the Z Kalia that I remember
in the preseason game who ran over kam
chancellor as a rookie but just look to
had you know a little more explosiveness
and just I don't know what I want to say
will want to whatever it may be running
the football and then DeMarcus Lawrence
who I'm still not gonna sit here and say
it's as good as it should be he did have
you know shoulder shoulder surgery in
the offseason but he caused that early
sack fumble that got them going in the
right direction alright I could go a lot
of different directions here but I love
the move that was made by Kyle Shanahan
your buddy
yeah after beating I was a good
statement on that's right it's Sunday
statement drafts that's how it fits yeah
given the game ball not not to a player
not to an assistant coach not to John
Lynch not to Jed York not to anybody
connected to the 49ers organization the
game ball went to his dad Mike Shanahan
who suffered right next to Kyle through
those multiple years of yes operating
within the confines of a dysfunctional
franchise and that's a great capper to
put on the Shanahan regime in wash you
didn't give the game ball to Mike and
it's gonna be a rough week for
Washington because four days after the
reunion game with Kyle Shanahan it's a
reunion game with Kirk Cousins oh right
great yeah yes yes get that thrown in
their face yeah yeah and they're lucky
it was a monsoon there yesterday cuz
Washington would have got I think run
over by the San Francisco 49ers so I'm
with you there alright I'm gonna go to a
team we haven't talked about yet today
but they deserve some love
Kliff Kingsbury sunday statement I'm
gonna give it to him because this is I I
mean this was a hiring that I had big
questions about like man you know Texas
Tech wasn't even that great and you know
what has he been around to be a great
NFL offensive pike
well you know he's a smart guy he works
hard he's willing to steal plays from
other teams I think all of that and
that's what good offensive coordinators
do but I think Kliff Kingsbury made a
statement yesterday again you know this
Arizona Cardinal team you sit here and
go wow they're three three and one you
know I think a lot of us thought they
were gonna be towards the bottom of
football as far as the worst teams in
the sport but he has been gutsy with
play calling doing different things on
the offensive side of the ball of course
Kyler Murray is impressive but then
chase Edmunds who was the other guy I
wanted to choose for the statement at
running back his ability to run the
football catch passes out of the
backfield that's added another weapon to
this offense that was needed badly so I
give Kliff Kingsbury in the Arizona
Cardinals a lot of credit for what
they're doing from the Fordham Rams
that's right just like Vince Lombardi
yes has the greatest brand
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports